[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara halbwegs guten abend und
willkommen schön dass sie dabei sind wie
auch norbert lehmann für den sport ein
wunder unter 5 wir haben unter anderem
diese themen für sie
eine bilanz vom klimaschutzminister
robert habeck bescheinigt deutschland
einen rückstand bei der energiewende und
kündigt große gesetzesvorhaben an
eine spektakuläre operation erstmals hat
ein mensch ein schweine herz als ersatz
organ bekommen
und ein prosit auf die 11 das hamburger
schmuckstück feiert fünften geburtstag
mit einer konzertserie und einem stolzen
blick zurück
beim klimaschutz hinke deutschland
gewaltig hinterher jetzt gelte es tempo
zu machen vor allem mit sehr viel mehr
windrädern und solaranlagen das ist grob
zusammengefasst die botschaft des neuen
klimaschutz ministers heute robert habe
gesagt deutschland müsse lernen besser
zu werden um die klimaschutzziele zu
erreichen
die hatte noch die vorgänger regierung
festgelegt bis 2030 sollen hierzulande
65 prozent weniger treibhausgase
ausgestoßen werden als im jahr 1990 bis
2045 heißt das ziel klimaneutral sein
was der grüne minister jetzt ändern will
damit das klappt berichtet thomas reich
hat wie viel sich der klimaminister
vorgenommen hat sah man schon daran wie
viel er unterm arm trug jede menge
papier und schautafeln für eine wii habe
gies nennt eröffnungsbilanz in sachen
klima so wie sie ausfällt könnte man sie
auch abrechnungs bilanz nennen mit der
vorgängerregierung die beim klimaschutz
viel liegen gelassen habe
wir starten nicht auf der ziellinie
sondern mit einem gehörigen rückstand
das tempo und die konsequenz müssen zu
nehmen im prinzip kann man über den
groben daumen sagen wir müssen dreimal
besser seien in allen bereichen der
ausstoß an treibhausgasen seit 2020 nur
wegen corona deutlich gefallen zuletzt
aber wieder gestiegen die bisherigen
anstrengungen reichten bei weitem nicht
aus so habeck da sind wir also und da
müssen wir in ein erstes klima paket
will er zu ostern vorlegen ein zweites
im sommer das sind die kernpunkte in
gebäuden sollen bis 2030 50 prozent der
wärme erneuerbar erzeugt werden die
eeg-umlage wird abgeschafft um
verbraucher zu entlasten
es soll eine solarpflicht für
gewerbliche neubauten geben für private
soll solar die regel sein und zwei
prozent der landesfläche sollen für
windkraft genutzt werden können
besonders da sind konflikte schon
absehbar mit bürgerinitiativen mit
ländern und kommunen die mit strengen
abstandsregeln den ausbau von anlagen
erschweren der bund kann das nicht
alleine entscheiden er braucht da die
zustimmung der länder und die brauchen
bei der regionalplanung und lokalen
planung auch das mitwirken der kommunen
dafür abstandsregeln vorgehalten werden
um verhinderungsplanung zu vertreiben
können die nicht länger bestehen bleiben
einen mühsamen prozess erwartet habe
immerhin klima experten bescheinigen ihm
dass die pläne in die richtige richtung
gingen
anderes großes thema impfpflicht oder
nicht und wenn ja für wen diese
entscheidung wird auf die
bundestagsabgeordneten zu kommen jeder
soll für sich entscheiden ohne
fraktionszwang so jedenfalls will es die
ampel und plädiert für gruppenanträge
von abgeordneten die union dagegen
fordert einen gesetzentwurf der
regierung stimmen aus den parteien zum
thema hat david gebhard gesammelt ja
nein vielleicht ist es die frage mit der
die bundestagsabgeordneten ins neue jahr
starten also ich persönlich habe immer
gesagt dass ich mich für eine allgemeine
impfpflicht aussprechen werde menschen
die das nicht wollen gegen ihren willen
dazu zu zwingen halte ich für nicht
verantwortbar dazu bin ich selbst als
abgeordneter noch gar nicht entschieden
wie ich mich dazu verhalten das breite
meinungsspektrum der ampel zur
impfpflicht daher der plan diese nicht
zur koalition sondern zur
fraktionsübergreifenden gewissensfrage
zu machen der bundestag hat
verantwortung gerade in den fragen von
gewissensentscheidungen und von daher
muss ich so deutlich noch mal machen
dass der glaube dass alleine eine
exekutive in der lage ist gesetzentwürfe
zu schreiben vollkommen falsch ist
verschiedene gruppen anträge stehen im
raum etwa die allgemeine impfpflicht ab
18 jahren eine altersabhängige ab 50
oder 60 zum beispiel oder die ablehnung
aus der union kommen stimmen die
fraktionsübergreifende anträge ablehnen
fordern die ampel regierung müsse einen
eigenen antrag mit mehrheit hinbekommen
beim thema impfen ist es so da ist jetzt
erstmal die regierung in der vorlage es
können jetzt nicht einzelne abgeordnete
machen sollen aber so gruppenanträge
laufen die sind gar nicht in der lage
die dimension dieses problems
tatsächlich im detail zu erfassen
innerhalb der ampel haar dann besonders
in der fdp viele mit der impfpflicht
drängen auf die gewissensentscheidungen
und attackieren die union ich halte es
wirklich für falsch sein seine
abgeordneten so an die seite zu drücken
dass sie sich wirklich für ein fehler
ich meine wir sollten und die union
sollte an der stelle jetzt auch mit ins
boot kommen und sagen wir machen das
nicht zu einer parteipolitischen frage
kommt die impfpflicht für wen sollte sie
gelten und ab wann viele fragen auch der
umsetzung und kontrolle sind noch so
offen wie kontrovers
ja warum wird hier so um formalitäten
gerungen kabinett in berlin weil die
parteien zwar auf der einen seite sehr
ernsthaft über die frage debattieren
wollen und das auch möglichst ohne sich
einen fraktionszwang erst einmal beugen
zu müssen von anfang an aber auf der
anderen seite auch die eigeninteressen
momentan noch nicht ganz ausblenden
können wir haben da auf der einen seite
die bundesregierung die kein echtes
interesse daran man kann einen eigenen
impfpflicht vorschlag vorzulegen pro
impfpflicht weil sie sich nicht sicher
sein kann ob sie dafür auch eine eigene
mehrheit hätte wir haben es gehört die
fdp hat sich immer sehr stark gemacht
gegen impfpflicht muss sich da jetzt
auch mittel und in den eigenen reihen
auch diskutieren auch die spd ist da
nicht ganz geschlossen der
spd-fraktionsvorsitzende hat heute noch
gesagt er glaubt dass große teile der
fraktion für eine impfpflicht stimmen
würden aber das sind eben nicht alle und
dann ist da auf der anderen seite die
union die auch noch nicht ganz
geschlossen ist in dieser frage und auch
noch intern diskutiert und diese
gelegenheit jetzt momentan aber auch
nutzt um druck auf die bundesregierung
zu machen und dafür auch eigene leute
zurück pfeift die anscheinend auch schon
an einem eigenen gesetzentwurf gesessen
haben alle sind sich im grunde genommen
einig man möchte sehr ernsthaft diese
wichtige frage diskutieren aber momentan
steht die debatte ja auch noch nicht
offiziell im bundestag an die erste
orientierung debatte soll in zwei wochen
kommen dann gibt es auch noch weitere
vorschläge das haben wir heute gehört
die man dann diskutieren kann bis dahin
gibt es wahrscheinlich noch weitere
abgrenzung gästen und kräftemessen
zwischen opposition und bundesregierung
die einschätzung unserer
hauptstadtkorrespondenten dankeschön
check unternahm
omikron breitet sich weiter aus in
deutschland inzwischen ist die neue
variante in mehr als 100.000 fällen
nachgewiesen worden entsprechend steigt
auch die gesamtzahl der neuinfektionen
laut robert koch institut wurden binnen
eines tages
45.600 90 fälle gemeldet
322 menschen starben mit oder an dem
virus die sieben tage incidents liegt
bei 300 87,9 die
weltgesundheitsorganisation warnt davor
mit 19 schon jetzt als endemische
erkrankung wie eine grippe anzusehen es
gebe noch große ungewissheit und das
virus entwickle sich ständig weiter die
whu rechnet damit dass sich in den
nächsten sechs bis acht wochen die
hälfte der einwohner europas mit omikron
infizieren wird
zu einem medizinischen meilenstein in
der
organtransplantation in den usa ist es
erstmals gelungen einem patienten ein
schweine herz einzusetzen das vom körper
nicht sofort abgestoßen wird ein
hoffnungsschimmer auch für viele
menschen in deutschland denn der bedarf
ist groß im jahr 2020 standen
hierzulande
528 menschen auf der warteliste für ein
herz 300 300
339 haben eines bekommen über die
chancen und risiken der neuen methode
berichten alexandra vacano und petra
neubauer
ich hatte die wahl zu sterben oder diese
transplantation vorzunehmen so david
bennett ein menschliches herz gab es für
den 57-jährigen todkranken nicht jetzt
schlägt das herz eines schweins in ihm
tier organspenden für menschen daran
arbeiten auch forscher im bayrischen
oberschleißheim circa 400 schweine haben
sie hier rund zwei drittel davon mit
genetisch veränderten herzen
das ziel ist natürlich zunächst einmal
den patienten die derzeit kein
menschliches spenderherz bekommen können
weil es einfach nicht genug gibt eine
option zu bieten trotzdem ein
lebensretter eine lebensrettende
transplantation zu bekommen wenn das
ganze mal etabliert ist kann es durchaus
sein dass man sozusagen langfristig
sogar dem schweineherzen den vorzug
geben würde schweine seien junge gesunde
verfügbare spender ihr stoffwechsel
ähnlich wie bei menschen trotzdem damit
das herz nicht abgestoßen wird muss das
erbgut der tiere verändert werden so
werden zum beispiel schweine gene
ausgeschaltet wie das wachstums gehen
damit dass schweine herz nicht zu groß
wird für den menschen der zellkern mit
dem veränderten erbgut wird in schweine
eizellen eingesetzt daraus wachsen
embryos heran die dann in die
gebärmutter einer sau eingesetzt werden
die schweine in oberschleißheim werden
streng geschützt vor viren und bakterien
wir haben hier einen hermetisch
abgeriegelten bestand ohne jeglichen
kontakt zu schweinen von außerhalb laut
experten hält ein schweine herz nach
einer transplantation ein bis zwei jahre
hoffnung aber auch skepsis die
ergebnisse werden über
absehbare zeit räume und nicht so gut
werden mit dem schweine organ wie mit
menschlichen organen so dass die
organspende die menschliche organspende
unverzichtbare bleibt zumindest für die
nächsten zehn jahre drei tage nach der
op geht es david bennett gut er hofft
nun darauf bald genesen das bett
verlassen zu können
die linke hat heute ihren
gegenkandidaten für frank-walter
steinmeier präsentiert er habe zwar
keinerlei chance bundespräsident zu
werden sagt gerhard trabert wolle aber
seine kandidatur nutzen um sein
lebensthema auf die tagesordnung zu
setzen armut in unserem reichen land
bobby cherry an stellt den parteilosen
arzt vor er gilt als arzt der armen
gerhard trabert allgemeinmediziner
professor und jetzt kandidat der linken
für das amt des bundespräsidenten als
solcher will der 65 jährige aus mainz
kämpfen gegen armut und soziale
ungerechtigkeit wir sind ein reiches
land wir können wir müssen mehr soziale
verantwortung übernehmen in diesem land
aber auch über die grenzen hinweg seit
jahrzehnten engagiert sich der
parteilose arzt für die medizinische
versorgung von obdachlosen
zudem kümmert er sich um flüchtlinge so
auch auf lesbos oder in nordsyrien eine
arbeit die man auch als staatsoberhaupt
nicht aufgeben müsste so trabert
vielleicht kann ja auch noch ein
bundespräsident einmal also alle zwei
wochen einmal beim arzt mobil weiter
unterwegs sein warum eigentlich nicht
die nähe zu erhalten zu menschen am
rande unserer gesellschaft die
nominierung von gerhard trabert durch
die linke eine einstimmige entscheidung
von partei und fraktion wir werden sehr
dafür dass er nicht nur ein angebot der
linken ist sondern dass er ein angebot
ist ein personelles angebot der genau
darauf hinweist dass die soziale
ungleichheit in diesem land so großes
trabert weiß seine chancen zum
bundespräsidenten gewählt zu werden sind
nicht groß doch die große bühne will er
nutzen für sein anliegen mehr soziale
gerechtigkeit
das eben parlament trauert um seinen
präsidenten davids das soli ist tut als
großen europäer würde ich der ihnen
kommissionspräsidentin von der leyen als
guten freund deutschlands kanzler scholz
applaus vor dem eu-parlament als zeichen
der wertschätzung für den italienischen
sozialdemokraten 13 jahre gehörte er dem
parlament an immer wieder setzte er sich
etwa für die belange von flüchtlingen
und obdachlosen ein da wird das soli
wurde 65 jahre alt
als die flutkatastrophe im vergangenen
sommer auch erftstadt in
nordrhein-westfalen traf riss das wasser
dort mehrere gebäude mit kein reines
unglück vermutet die staatsanwaltschaft
und durchsuchte heute büros und
wohnräume unter anderem beim betreiber
der ansässigen kiesgrube im dauerregen
war die grube vollgelaufen an der
abbruchkante rutschte dann immer mehr
erde in das loch möglicherweise weil der
hochwasserschutz weil der grube
mangelhaft war glauben die ermittler
außerdem könnte es eine unzulässig
steile böschung gegeben haben
ein kultur spaceship zwischen himmel und
erde so nennt udo lindenberg die
elbphilharmonie in hamburg vor genau
fünf jahren war eröffnung längst sind
alle so begeistert dass kaum mehr jemand
über die zehn jahre bauzeit oder die
gigantische bausumme redet ob das
schmuckstück auch die wirtschaftlichen
erwartungen erfüllt beantwortet
christina hansen
sie ist ein strahlendes monument für die
kultur geworden die musik kathedrale an
der elbe hat alle erwartungen
übertroffen
bis zur corona zwangspause waren die
konzerte sofort ausverkauft die
elbphilharmonie ist ein wesentlicher
teil des hamburger selbstverständnisses
geworden die elbphilharmonie ist
tatsächlich ja gestartet mit dem
anspruch wahrzeichen hamburgs zu werden
ich glaube das ist die mittlerweile
geworden und nicht nur außen
marketingversprechen der stadt heraus
sondern aus einer ganz tief empfundenen
emotionen der hamburgerinnen und
hamburger ein teures wahrzeichen rund
800 millionen euro hat es einst gekostet
viel mehr als ursprünglich erwartet eine
bauruine drohte doch die lage mitten im
strom die spektakuläre architektur zieht
nun besucher aus dem in und ausland
scharenweise in konzerte und auf die
öffentliche plaza aber ich bin jetzt
schon das dritte mal hier in den letzten
zwei jahren ich muss immer einmal hoch
ich finds wunderschön das was davor
alles gedacht haben schlecht geräte
haben wir zu viel geld gekostet aber
letztendlich ist wirklich toll macht
hamburg auch noch ein stück schöner und
es rechnet sich für die stadt die
übernachtungszahlen sind um 15 prozent
gestiegen
14,5 millionen menschen waren bisher auf
der plaza das heißt mehr menschen als
ich in dem zeitraum schloss
neuschwanstein angeschaut haben und es
ist ein anker für den besuch hamburgs
auch der konzertsaal hat die hoffnungen
erfüllt die besten solisten und
orchester aus der ganzen welt treten auf
oft vor zuhörern die sonst eher nicht in
konzerte gehen auch deshalb kommen
künstler gerne wieder ich bin der
meinung das hast du den zuhörer jahres
ball im saal wird es viele geben die dem
zauber der klassischen musik erliegen
und im moment gibt es sogar noch
konzertkarten seit der pandemie ist auch
dass elbphilharmonie publikum noch
zurückhaltend jetzt
zum sport norbert und zum wirbel um den
serbischen tennis star djokovic hatte
dafür nun doch vorerst in melbourne
bleiben und bereitet sich dort auch auf
die australian open vor aber seine
teilnahme wie ist nicht sicher jetzt
droht ein neuer ärger wegen möglicher
falscher angaben in seinem
einreiseformular
novak djokovic trainiert aber bilder
davon gibt es nicht nur jenes von seinem
ein reisedokument indem er angibt nicht
über ein drittland australien eingereist
zu sein bilder aus dem internet
vermitteln das gegenteil djokovic schlug
zunächst von serbien zum training nach
marbella anreise also aus spanien auf
die missachtung von einreise pflichten
stehen in australien aber haftstrafen
der korona fall djokovic wird nun zum
formaljuristischen krimi und djokovic
hat angegeben er wäre in serbien gewesen
dabei war er in spanien mehrere tage und
das hat er einfach verschwiegen richter
anthony kelly hat djokovic zwar aus der
hotel quarantäne entlassen doch
einwanderungsminister alex horne kann
das visum wieder einkassieren die zeit
drängt am donnerstag findet die
auslosung statt djokovic ist an nummer
eins gesetzt noch
drastisch steigende corona infektion
führen zur absage zahlreiche sport
begegnungen gerade im eishockey in
einigen ligen und verbänden wird jetzt
darüber diskutiert die teilnahme am
olympischen eishockey turnier in peking
abzusagen
in europa sind fast alle eishockey ligen
betroffen allein in deutschland gab es
in diesem winter bereits 30
spielausfälle im moment sind vier teams
komplett in quarantäne
die deutsche eishockey liga in not
geschäftsführer tripcke sieht das
olympische turnier der in gefahr ich
glaube das ist ein super ziel für alle
sportler und das will man auch kein
wegnehmen aber wenn man gesehen hat
jetzt bei der u 20-wm dass man daran im
prinzip auch noch drei tagen aufgeben
musste fehlt mir so ein bisschen die
fantasie warum das in china viel besser
werden abbruch der u 20
weltmeisterschaft in kanada vor gut
einer woche die nfl verbietet ihren
profis aus nordamerika den auftritt in
peking die besten also fehlen ohnehin
der welt eishockey verband will am
donnerstag über das weitere vorgehen mit
den nationalen verbänden beraten
das war es auch schon volkssports
dankeschön maklern die nacht wird
frostig die details hat gleich als den
teller christian sievers begrüßt sie um
viertel vor zehn im heute-journal hier
übernimmt morgen diana pareigis einen
schönen abend wünsche ich ihnen noch
alles gute und auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter die
hochdruckbrücke wird vorübergehend
gestört von einer front die etwas regen
und auch etwas schnee mit bringt das
muss man sich so vorstellen dass es
hauptsächlich dann sprühregen oder
schneegriesel ist und in der nacht wird
es platz nach norden hin hauptsächlich
durch überfrierende nässe aber auch mit
den herannahenden worten die etwas regen
bringen im süden lockert es auf
teilweise bildet sich nebel und dort
wird es am kältesten mit temperaturen
bis minus 14 grad an den alpen nach
norden hin ist es milder teils frostfrei
zum beispiel richtung nordsee bei plus
zwei grad morgen tagesverlauf also
dichte wolken die weiter richtung dann
ist innere ziehen ein paar flocken und
etwas regen kann hier ausfallen das wird
nicht viel sein hinter der front lockert
es auf etwas sonnenschein oder auch im
süden da scheint die sonne dann durchaus
verbreitet bei höchsten temperaturen von
minus zwei grad am alpenrand hier bleibt
es beim dauerfrost und plus sieben grad
richtung nordsee dort wird es am
mildesten sein sonst gibt es auch in den
nächsten tagen zum beispiel am
donnerstag im südwesten temperaturen bei
minus ein bis plus acht grad damit ein
schöner abend